good morning Hank it's Monday
nerdfighters often ask us if we're
religious a topic we've been reluctant
to discuss over the years mostly because
the quality of discourse about religion
on the Internet is atrocious
that said many nerdfighters know that a
decade ago I worked as a chaplain at a
Children's Hospital and I was also
briefly enrolled in although I never
actually attended the University of
Chicago's Divinity School so today I'm
going to share everything I have to say
about religion hopefully that will lead
to a productive and thoughtful
conversation although given the history
of the internet and conversations about
religion probably not okay hey so I
would submit that almost all human lives
are usually lived in a state of like
functional nihilism very few of us
believe that human life is devoid of all
meaning and that all we should do is
answer to our base urges and fulfill our
basic desires and try to distract
ourselves from pain or fear or
unpleasantness but almost all of us act
as if we believe that like I have this
massive parallel processing unit that
sits on top of my neck that I could use
to like contribute to cancer research or
write a novel or puzzle through quantum
mechanics and I have this amazing body
that I could use to plant trees or fight
wildfires or harvest food for the poor
and Grover that time I said I have an
amazing body I don't mean that I have an
amazing body I mean everybody as Ike
it's amazing what our bodies can do but
I don't usually do any that stuff ain't
most of my free time is spent like
watching television playing video games
or searching for wools
Christians Muslims atheists whatever all
of us share this worldview almost none
of us would abandon our comforts to help
others almost all of us would
acknowledge that much of our time each
day is wasted in short Hank if we just
judge humans by their actions we look
like a bunch of nihilists but we aren't
nihilus because we all feel called to
make the world better to understand and
observe the universe to make art to
bring beautiful things into life to
contribute in some way to the human
experiment everybody wants their lives
to matter to have meant something that
call to meaning is the foundation of
religious worldviews but it's also the
foundation of successful secular
worldviews which is why I don't really
care to debate the existence of God with
people I can't imagine you wake up in
the middle of the night in your houses
covered in smoke and you hear an
invisible voice shout your house is on
fire
Hank in that situation I would find it
like totally uninteresting to have a
discussion about where that voice was
coming from and how it got
the house and was it god or a fireman I
would just you know leave in short Hank
for me at least debating the mere
existence of God is a way of avoiding
the deeper and more devastating question
of how we are going to bring meaning to
human life
I think that's broadly speaking the
point of religion religion is
essentially a response to revelation and
that revelation almost always calls us
to embrace meaning or if it doesn't
innately exist than to create meaning
but that's also true for atheistic
humanism we are all facing the same
question what are we going to do with
our consciousness will we seek to fight
poverty or climate change or disease or
war or spend all our resources ensuring
that we have a beautifully manicured
lawn with absolutely no weeds sorry I'm
not a bit of a lawn kick at the moment
because my next-door neighbor is not
terribly happy with me for leading the
country for two months during the lawn
growing season it's just grass dude
actually it's not just grass that's his
problem it's also a lot of dandelions so
what are we gonna do about consciousness
and how are we gonna balance our urge to
be more than nihilists with our need to
blunt the sharp edges of consciousness
with funny stuff like Paula Deen writing
Paula Deen writing me or humpy Hank
those are interesting questions Hank and
nerdfighteria has been talking about
those questions for years now some of us
through religious lens some of us
through a secular lens but the lens
doesn't interest me as much as the
questions sorry this video didn't
contain many jokes to make up for here
is a baby rhinoceros also as penance I
will eat 36 disgusting sandwiches on
Friday Hank don't forget to be awesome I
will see you on Wednesday